foreign
Wembley England followers many without
tickets storm the turnstiles
stewards overwhelmed and the police
absent others appear to take the law
into their own hands
a dangerous hostile environment for fans
attending the nation's biggest game in
half a century
Ian St John was at the match with his
family their Memories the morning after
of violence as well as defeat the second
we got out the car there was pandemonium
outside you know there was guys
urinating in the street defacing
property swearing abusing people glass
bottles flying thousands of fans had
gathered to drink outside Wembley hours
before the 8 PM kickoff the atmosphere
souring when ticketless fans breached a
security Cordon outside the ground
the Metropolitan Police has made 86
arrests and around the country police
reported almost 900 football related
incidents clearly there was behavior
that was wholly unacceptable from a
minority of people and policing did deal
with it on the night and we are
conducting a post investigation to deal
with anybody who committed criminality
on the evening the fa has launched an
investigation after what was intended as
a celebration of football at Wembley
turned into a disaster for the national
game and it's bid to host the 2030 World
Cup
the final here was supposed to Showcase
England's ability to host major events
instead it was an embarrassment for the
Football Association and the government
which waived quarantine restrictions for
hundreds of football VIPs so they could
be here to see it
one Englishman who knows what it is to
win a final said a bid will have to
convince FIFA the country can clean up
its act it doesn't send a great message
out but they know that if we hold the
World Cup here then the measures will be
taken to ensure that that doesn't happen
so in in one stupid point it's a good
thing it's cropped up and so people can
nail it when we get it get it right and
we've got plenty of time to get it right
eight years it wasn't just Wembley that
was out of control in Leicester Square
in London England fans trashed their own
City in a manner previous foreign host
venues would recognize in one depressing
sense football did come home after all
Paul Kelso Sky News at Wembley